on Friday the Daily Mail obtained and
published what it said were exclusive
photos from the set of Disney's new woke
Snow White live-action remake as we know
Disney is in the process of slowly
cannibalizing itself eating away at its
own legacy until soon mercifully there
will be nothing left they are recreating
all of their own classic films releasing
new lifeless remake versions that are
similar to the old versions except shorn
of all the charm and creativity and
humor and beauty and you know all that
stuff you don't need they ask themselves
hey what would our best films be like if
they didn't have any of the qualities
that made them special each remake has
earned increasingly diminishing returns
and so Disney responds by frantically
blaming every new failure on racism and
bigotry